hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday Monday was it April I'm gonna go
with April April 25th 2016 what's going
on hello how are you how are ya I just
got back from Iowa connected through
Phoenix could not get a direct flight
out of Des Moines Des Moines
International Airport in Des Moines Iowa
one of the greatest international
airports you'll ever go to my hotel was
right next door to it I was there for
about three hours before the show okay I
think I heard three Jets take off that's
[ __ ] awesome it's a decent sized
Airport too but there's very little
people you know come out of an cornfield
you know getting out of there death
metal [ __ ] band rehearsal and going
to the Des Moines International Airport
to [ __ ] go anywhere evidently breezed
right through security all the whole
thing one I love [ __ ] I love little
airports I love him the way some of
these chicks love that dude left that
[ __ ] band that was poor [ __ ]
little girls what a [ __ ] the parents
film their kids in embarrassing moment I
can see if siblings do it but it always
seems like a lot of parents they just
film their [ __ ] kids and it's just
like all those girls who [ __ ] got
filmed or film themselves you really
should take it down but once it's up
there you get you finished you [ __ ]
done you can't run for president with
that on your [ __ ] profile history I
wonder who's gonna be the first one to
run for president right and then they
just pull up you know some clip from
their childhood on Facebook on YouTube
or some [ __ ] some video of them either
saying something [ __ ] up or getting
hit in the balls and then crying like a
little girl or something like that you
know do you member that time when that
[ __ ] dead fat kid threw that thing at
that the little kid and the kid ran over
he threw the skateboard at him and the
kid [ __ ] fell down and let out a cry
like
I can't even [ __ ] do it in that
moment that kids life as far as any sort
of leadership role is over you know and
I know what you say and you go well look
at him Billy's out there eating
ring-dings running around with this
high-pitched voice who's gonna follow
that into battle it's like people
[ __ ] develop later in life you know
you should have seen me when I was a kid
no better yet it was good thing it
didn't [ __ ] orange hair
you know [ __ ] total introvert lunatic
lunatic literally could not talk to a
girl thought my face turned beet red I
was a [ __ ] mess if there was [ __ ]
videos of that or all the [ __ ] ass
kickings I took I remember a girl beat
me up enough when I was in third grade
this fifth grade girl beat me up because
I was playing with this kickball and her
sister came up was playfully taking it
away from me so I ran up to take it back
and she was running along the school and
I ripped it out of her hands you know
used to playing with boys and she's kind
of careened into the side of the school
which of course is made of brick because
you know if it catches fire you know you
want something to be able to rebuild on
you know I mean all those rugs and
everybody inside are gonna go up like a
[ __ ] bowling alley but you want the
main structure because the town's got to
pay for it so anyways he goes into the
building hit her head and as I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm sorry
her [ __ ] sister showed up there's a
big difference between third grade and
fifth grade she looked like a substitute
teacher to me that's how much [ __ ]
older she looked at me and she [ __ ]
just rained these [ __ ] punches down
on me
and I held it together you know you know
I waited to the end of the round I knew
I was gonna lose the decision and I was
all right I was trying to walk it off it
really [ __ ] hurt and then some girls
I forget what she said to me but it
actually made me cry you said something
supportive I have no idea so yeah now if
there was video of that I mean that's it
if they ever had I mean this is a guy
you won't run in the country get beat up
by a girl and starts crying
ah hell is he gonna keep America safe
how's he gonna keep children safe how is
he gonna keep Jesus safe and then that's
gonna be end of the end of it all these
[ __ ] people you've just film your
[ __ ] kids all this oversharing I
don't give a [ __ ] that your kids 13
years old is in love with a boy band
stop filming the [ __ ] time you know
and I'm not talking about the kids who
filmed themselves but sometimes it's
parents which is really weird
like I hate those families that I'll get
into their care van and they start
singing songs or doing dances and they
just wow that's the funnest family ever
you know I can see through it you know
the second the camera turns off the dad
turns into Joe Jackson beating our asses
all over the [ __ ] house anyway sorry
that was just a complete a complete left
turn but uh I don't know I'm actually
fascinated with that dude leaving the
boy band if the height of the [ __ ]
popularity you know just as far as you
know being in the entertainment business
going all right now how do you do this
did he make enough [ __ ] money you
know goddamn well his manager and
everyone around him stole from the guy
did he make enough [ __ ] money the
thing about it is is he's so young he's
gonna look like that guy for a while so
it's not like you know he's at that age
where he can just slip back into the you
know like at my age I'm gonna be 48 in
ten years gonna be 58 I'm gonna look way
[ __ ] different okay
48 is the last sort of like you know I
could go down maybe play some pickup
hoop and I could get picked last that's
it and then 48 to 58 that's you know
when you start getting the chicken neck
you know you start getting your fares
and order hands like [ __ ] 21 you know
it's barely gonna be 30 right a little
over 30 I should say so if I was him I
would shave off that [ __ ] facial
there and I would just start eating
McDonald's and I've just become a fat
[ __ ] and then I just wait to see how
long you don't be a fat guy if you're a
fat guy then
then you like feel like famous in a
different way like everybody looks at
you but you don't have a show you know
if you get to that level of fat all
right don't get like circus fat it'd be
funny if he did that he was just so good
at everything he became like the fattest
guy ever you know and then everyone
who's staring at him again he's just
like [ __ ] I just I can't not be famous
anyways good luck to that kid and and
parents take take down the [ __ ]
videos you goddamn kids you [ __ ]
weirdos there's probably some pervert
out there that likes to jerk off to
[ __ ] girls crying - boy band members
who just left there's probably a fetish
at this point you know there's nothing
else left a jerk-off you create a new
literally create a new type of porn
alright anyways ahead now I know what
all you guys think I'm gonna talk about
you know you're gonna be like oh I saw a
big sports story oh boy oh boy I hope I
D I hope he didn't [ __ ] record his
podcast before that went down well I
didn't I didn't okay I will talk about
that later I just don't give a [ __ ] the
way I used to but let's get to what I
really give a [ __ ] about the only two
things I give a [ __ ] about right now and
[ __ ] game five back in Atlanta the
Boston Celtics I missed every [ __ ]
second of the last two games cuz I was
on the road I missed all of them was
[ __ ] driving I didn't have my foam so
my [ __ ] leg was going dumb numb I had
to [ __ ] pull over at a rest area you
know stretch it out you know what I mean
keep my head on a swivel looking for
[ __ ] truckers questioning their
sexuality and [ __ ] what are they
these serial killers serial killers love
a [ __ ] rest area so anyways I missed
I missed all of that all I know is that
they came back they tied it up I was so
happy and I did see the clip of whoever
that was was it smart on the [ __ ]
spot on the Celtics barely getting
touched and literally throwing himself
out of bounds
I know he got fine five grand they
should have given him at least like a
thousand dollars off just because he
kind of hurt himself he went up so high
that was one of the worst [ __ ] dives
I've ever seen in my life
and I mean I even think to the Celtics
probably teased him about that by the
time we got to the locker rooms like
Jesus Christ who just flopped to the
ground
[ __ ] jumping up in the air anyways
and the st. Louis Blues what the you
know I already went through a heartache
with my team I [ __ ] hitched my wagon
to you guys you get up three two one I
knew I [ __ ] knew they had to win Game
five Game five you know so so [ __ ] up
about a seven-game series you're up
three games to [ __ ] one and you're
thinking like that just [ __ ] win one
no you [ __ ] have to win Game five
because the second you don't win Game
five the last two games the pressures on
you all of a sudden goes oh no wait a
minute
pls Game five uh the other guys when the
next game is tied up Chicago Blackhawks
kept the momentum going into cage seven
the state Louis Blues have a history of
playoff collapses you know that's all is
saying on the [ __ ] oh my god oh my
god I I had such belief in this team I
still believe me when I'm [ __ ] three
games to one and I was sitting down and
I said without a doubt I said the
[ __ ] Celtics were gonna win Game
three I called it and then I talked [ __ ]
and I said like I said the Celtics were
gonna win Game three the [ __ ] st.
Louis Blues are gonna win Game six and
they were up three to one before I went
on stage in Kansas City and I was
thinking like alright they got that
[ __ ] was it Elliott net he's playing
great they got they have a size
advantage
Yatta Yatta I think well this looks
pretty good so I go on stage right I do
my [ __ ] and dick jokes for about a good
hour and a half I come off the stage had
a great [ __ ] show and I walk in the
greenroom and all the [ __ ] uh
Blackhawks Kia [ __ ] cheesin ear
eirGrid they cut to Mike Milbury and I
see the final score was it was Oh like
six to three and I was just like what
the [ __ ] happened I'll tell you what
happened 500 [ __ ] goals is what
happened I've yet to see the highlights
of that but uh I'm recording my podcast
right now and I'm and then I got to go
over to the writers room here working on
episode 3 written by yours truly for
next season
who hypes a cartoon [ __ ] 13 months
before it comes out this guy and then
I'm gonna be I'm taping the Blues game
so I'm not gonna be on Twitter or any of
that [ __ ] just in case you guys you know
send me scores and [ __ ] but I'm gonna I
can't wait to [ __ ] watch that game
it's gonna be great either way I want to
see st. Louis win but uh you just have
to respect the [ __ ] greatness of the
Chicago Blackhawks during this error if
they come back from this I mean it's
just you know it goes beyond you know
you got to have guys like that guys that
have one [ __ ] where they went to
already two or three to I think they
didn't they still want to win more it's
very rare it's very rare most of the
times a guy wins one he's done you know
or he wins three and he just says [ __ ]
he keeps eating until his belt buckle
bursts you know that's what you usually
[ __ ] happens with superstars so
anyways I can't wait to see that and
then the game Game five of the Celtics
is tomorrow night so I'll be taking both
of those this is such a [ __ ] great
time of year it's a little bit of
advertising Sherry's Barry's all right
there's no there's no one quite like mom
all right that started creepy every mom
is unique and we wouldn't want to change
the thing take talk about your mom or
your wife's quirks why do they [ __ ]
do that no I'm not going to and with
Mother's Day just around the corner I
have a great way to show you to show Mom
how much you appreciate her surprise I
shouldn't read that done that Tom Brady
ship before I got into this I'm gonna be
in a mood all right and with Mother's
Day just around the corner I have a
gripe I have a great way to show you to
show Mom how much you appreciate her
surprise mom with something
did and it's unique as she is Cheri's
berries mom I love you to death you are
as unique as chocolate-covered
strawberries that's where I put you on
the [ __ ] pyramid it goes you you
you're in Thai you're a tie with
chocolate-covered strawberries alright
right now get Sherry's bear he's freshly
dipped strawberries starting at $19.99
plus shipping or double the berries for
only $10 more this is an exclusive offer
for my listeners go to berries comm
click on the microphone at the top right
corner of and type in my code bur
berries dipped in milk white and dark
chocolaty goodness topped with rich
chocolate chips chopped nuts since this
signature swizzles huge fresh delicious
juicy delicious you pick the delivery
date you want and it's guarantee
customer satisfaction is always
guaranteed or your money back it's a
win-win now here's the only way to get
this amazing deal for us we dipped
strawberries starting at only $19.99 or
double the berries for just $10 more
this is an exclusive offer for my
listeners only and every other podcast
that they advertise on when you use my
code Burpee you are our visit berries
calm BER our IES calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and click in bur that's berries calm
click on the microphone and into the
code bar this is a limited time offer
and Mother's Day is next week make sure
to order now they're [ __ ] delicious
so everybody tells me everybody tells me
they're [ __ ] delicious
they have Falken delish
but you know you might want to get her a
[ __ ] brush too or something you know
mine I'm just saying you don't I mean
get a little a little more bang for your
buck all right pearl flowers everybody
slow forward throw parol flowers mom has
always been an expert on everything
cooking relationship advice fixing your
cuts and bruises talk about your mom
wife why did they do that the only you
know well I got hit by a Jeep right and
I bike was all [ __ ] up when I was
knocked out for a second and then I woke
up in the middle of the street laying on
the double line that got out and this
guy got out of the Jeep crying going oh
my god I
my atom and then I went into the house
and I was like mom I got hit by a card
she's like well that's what you get for
not looking both ways you idiot and I
was like you know what someday I'm gonna
have a successful podcast and I'm
sending her flowers sorry I just had to
I had to honor my contract there until
that a personal story about my mom or my
wife one thing you can you can't go to
her for advice on is what to give her
get it for Mother's Day not to worry
you'll look like an expert on Mother's
Day when you use ProFlowers get mom 100
blooms with a free glass vase for only
$19.99 plus shipping and handling or
make her day extra special upgrade to a
premium vase and add gourmet chocolates
for just $9.99 more go to proflowers.com
today and use my code burr you choose
the delivery date you want and it's
guaranteed it's a no brainer here is the
only way to get a hundred blooms with a
free glass face starting at $19.99 visit
proflowers.com click on the blue
microphone in the top right hand corner
and type in / b you are r that's plov
proflowers.com click on the microphone
and type in Buryatia the [ __ ] Yana
alright Dollar Shave Club everybody
mommy more on these there's two more
will do it - and - don't wait though
all right where are we where are we
where the hell are we there it is there
it is
so I had to put the advertising
everything on the same [ __ ] thing oh
by the way Jesus Christ what a [ __ ]
week huh with Prince dying my god
watching all those uh those clips of
them just live you know what I never
[ __ ] saw him in concert he came out
here and did like 20 shows sold out at
the the LA forum
I remember Nia went and I was just I
forget where the [ __ ] I was just on the
road it was like the first couple of
nights I had gigs still out here and
then I left you know for like did it
like a ten day run and he knocked out
all those shows of some [ __ ] and I came
back and I remember thinking hey you
know and I'll catch him on the next one
and unfortunately that's not how life
works and I got to tell you though like
the level that that guy affected people
I mean they literally lit up the Eiffel
Tower in purple I mean as far as an
artist that's about as it's about as big
as honor as you get all these [ __ ]
like monuments around the world getting
lit up in purple man I I hadn't like I
knew that we loved him here I had no
idea like the level of fame that that
guy had man it's [ __ ] crazy so the 57
Jesus Christ I'm 48 that's all I was
thinking like good lord
gotta lay off the sauce anyways I want
to thank everybody came out to all my my
shows this this past weekend had a great
[ __ ] time play one of the most
beautiful theatres I've ever played to
play the Fox Theater in st. Louis and
they take you upstairs and if you ever
get a chance to take a tour of the place
you have to see some of the signatures
that are on the wall
please don't sign the [ __ ] wall
there's like [ __ ] people did that
next to like Stevie Ray Vaughan's like
one of my pet peeves is when somebody
[ __ ] huge signs a wall and then all
these [ __ ] jerk-offs right like
within the name you know what I mean
it's like you know we're near that guy
get that you shouldn't be sign on the
same [ __ ] wall
David Bowie was really cool David Bowie
actually signed next to his name but he
just scribbled his you can't even tell
it's all my [ __ ] hypocrite so I
signed near his but what was so cool
was the whole Stevie Ray David Bowie's
story from back in the day when Stevie
Ray went to was at the Monterey Jazz
Festival and they got booed off stage
and David Bowie was in the crowd but
loved Stevie's playing and afterwards
came up to him and blah blah blah that's
how we ended up playing on his let's
dance album and then he wanted Stevie to
go out on tour at them and Stevie just
wasn't feeling it he went to some of the
rehearsals and just like I can't [ __ ]
do this I want to go back to Texas and
play in my trio started all over again
and then became a giant on his own
rather than being part of David's band
and just the two of them just to be that
close like Louis Jerry Lewis
of course now am I forgetting Sammy
Davis jr. Tony Orlando just some a bunch
of random [ __ ] too and all this [ __ ]
from the 80s like the Thompson Twins all
this crazy stuff in there and they
really kept it well and Stevie signed it
twice once in 1987 and then another time
I think right before he died and like
the instep tour and I got there a little
bit late so I didn't get a chance to see
the theatre like the actual theatre
where people were sitting thank God
until after I did the show because that
would've been a little intimidating came
out afterwards was [ __ ] amazing and
had a great show and then the next day I
went to went to Kansas City and played
this sprint and I did a run with J
Kenneth Branagh and we wanted to get
barbecue and we trying to figure out
where to go that's right and they told
us to go to that [ __ ] Oklahoma Joe's
or some [ __ ] so we [ __ ] pull up there
and there's like a [ __ ] two-hour line
outside the place and I'm just sitting
there like there's no [ __ ] way this
is the line for this place but the
Royals had a game so I guess it's like a
family tradition out there people just
do that [ __ ] so we were like well [ __ ]
that place so the next place I had on my
list to maybe try out was this other
place q39 and it's the best part of a
queue I've had since saws when I was in
Alabama
it was [ __ ] it was the best I will
say it's the best brisket I ever had we
both ordered a couple of combo plates so
um you know we ended up having the
smoked chicken brisket ribs and the [ __ ]
else was that oh and him of course
pulled pork and it was [ __ ] amazing
but I have to tell you dude right after
that man I felt like I've I just I'm too
old to eat like that
I mean I'll spare you the [ __ ]
details but my body was just like yeah
you know you ever see somebody show up
at a club and they're already drunk like
how quickly they get thrown back out
to traffic yet that that's what happened
with me it was not a it was not a good
thing was not a good thing at all so
anyways but it was delicious and I
didn't even eat that much oh wait a
minute I did then we got dessert too
yeah it was kind of a bad day it was a
bad thing no it's funny I didn't eat
[ __ ] for the rest of the [ __ ] night
but um had a great time later on that
night I hung out with a bunch of friends
I've been going to Kansas City for a
long time so that a buddy mine out there
who built my my first web site him and
his wife showed up so we were just
hanging out having drinks just having a
great time and then the last day was I
got to go up to Iowa and Ames Iowa just
north of Des Moines and I finally went
to that state during a sunny month and
it was green and it was [ __ ]
beautiful
and Des Moines really underrated city
[ __ ] gorgeous this river runs right
through it and I got this beautiful
two-mile loop that you can walk around I
wish I had time to do that I forgot that
that was their ID like I said I hadn't
been in Iowa since I played penguins and
Cedar Rapids which I heard is no longer
there because the river overflowed or
some [ __ ] but anyways just had a had a
great time up there and I got to tell
you that's the [ __ ] place to own a
Ferrari Iowa that is the [ __ ] place
man because you see if you'll riding
around on motorcycles with no helmets on
and [ __ ] that is a place to own a
motorcycle that is the place to own a
[ __ ] supercar that is the [ __ ]
place to own a gun you have to have a
gun these [ __ ] it [ __ ] who live on
the coast and they're all jammed in with
people it makes sense that you don't
want everybody having a gun alright but
this is tipping point where the
population becomes so [ __ ] little
that then you're kind of on your own out
there
alright so if you [ __ ] weird-ass
neighbor shows up dressed like
Leatherface I mean you're gonna call the
[ __ ] cops by the time I was joking on
stage by the time they drive up your
driveway like half your family is [ __ ]
dead that driveways I swear to god some
of these some of these spreads are like
I don't know they're like [ __ ] they
look like they're like a like you could
land a goddamn dc-10 on the damn thing
so alright so here it is the big news
the big news this week that I found when
I got up right was actually I didn't
find it till I connected I flew from Des
Moines to Phoenix and then I connected
you know get my connecting flight and it
was late and I looked at my Twitter and
people started sending me all this [ __ ]
about Tom Brady the suspension somehow
somehow it came back it [ __ ] blew my
mind I was always under the impression
that like either way once you appealed
it that last thing was the final thing
I've never seen an appeal of an appeal
maybe there's been one I just remember I
remember when Al Davis wanted to move
the Raiders and they're like no you
can't do it and he goes well I'm [ __ ]
doing it anyways and then they had a
court battle and he won and that was it
the NFL just said fine maybe there was a
bunch of Appeals on that but that one
came out of nowhere and I don't know man
I don't want to sit here and [ __ ] be
a big baby about it or anything like
that but I did just really seems like it
just went above and beyond it's just
really extra I don't I don't understand
I don't get the [ __ ] NFL I really
don't I don't get why certain things you
know you knock a woman out in an
elevator you get four games you get two
games at first right then they bumped it
up to four because everybody bitched and
then they like oh no wait a minute wait
and we mean you're out of football for
good you know the subtext of that of
course was no we're gonna lose a bunch
of [ __ ] money from women and guys who
remotely give a [ __ ] about women aren't
gonna buy our [ __ ] jerseys and [ __ ]
so now all of a sudden we give a [ __ ]
right so I just have to think that this
really isn't a money thing they actually
lose money when Tom's not playing so I
really think this is just personal the
Patriots did something to piss off the
[ __ ] NFL I know a lot of you guys want
Patriots fans think I'm just trying to
make up an excuse but the reality is is
the NFL the only thing they give a [ __ ]
about is money alright the way they
handled all those concussions the way
they finally did that [ __ ] payout
the way they make money off of raising
cancer awareness by having pink jerseys
not letting you know that only 3% of the
money or whatever goes to research and
they pocket the other 97% the way
whenever they put a camera on you know
the servicemen and women that they
hooked up you know gave them free
tickets and then they count that as a
[ __ ] commercial and they charge
whatever branch of service those people
are in you know how filthy they are
there and only give a [ __ ] about money
you know Tom Brady's Captain America
like the Patriots a nut the guy looks
like a movie star and they make more
money if he's in the game and you're
talking about literally a concierge
worth of air they appealed it in one and
the NFL still was like no [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you so it's just it has to be personal
because and I don't want to name any
[ __ ] names here okay
there's other guys just as big as him
who had some really questionable [ __ ]
[ __ ] that went way beyond [ __ ] air
pressure in a ball all right and it was
just like yeah whatever no biggie
no blood no foul so yeah I think it's
official at this point that up as a
Patriots fan I am NOT paranoid when I
say the NFL [ __ ] hates the Patriots
and has it out for him
because they're actually shooting
themselves in the foot monetarily here
over [ __ ] air pressure over something
that they lost in court and like a
[ __ ] year ago so I don't know I don't
know what we did I would love to know
behind the scenes it's got to be some
Robert Kraft [ __ ] I would think you know
I can't really think of anything else
because you know I'm trying to be honest
here but like you know some of the other
infractions without naming names I'm
trying to be a class act here
certain things that went through the
mail wink wink
you know just [ __ ] like that and it's
just dad nothing no story and not to
mention you know the Colts owner in his
own [ __ ] investigation they found out
that for their footballs were also under
inflated so you're talking about going
on almost a year and a half ago that
this happened this [ __ ] still [ __ ]
going so I mean alright the NFL hates us
in know Tom Brady for four games I guess
that's you know whatever we're still
gonna win
what do good we're still gonna [ __ ]
win all you're gonna do is just make
Bill Belichick a better [ __ ] coach
and he already prepared for this last
year so when we get [ __ ] Janeane
Garofalo in there again I think he goes
to it too I'm looking forward to it
all right there you go there's all of
that type of stuff
what a [ __ ] weekend I had man I can't
tell you how much fun I had going out
there and doing those shows man and
working on my act and all that it's
great I have like I have the best
[ __ ] life I could possibly have right
now I'm writing on this the exact
[ __ ] show I want to do with a bunch
of hilarious people during the week and
every other week I get to continue my
dream doing stand-up comedy so and I'm
working towards taping another space
spatial special later on this year and
I'm also starting to get the audio
together for hopefully a vinyl release
of my show at Madison Square Garden
obviously I want that one to come out
after my stand-up special but uh you
know I'm hoping to do let go like I'm
not going to say when I'm hoping to do
with that vinyl album but it's gonna be
[ __ ] cool if I do it right if I don't
[ __ ] it up alright so anyways here we go
let's read some questions here for the
week bill when I travel out of town for
games I bring the stick oh this is about
foam rollers consuit I'm telling that
foam roller changed my [ __ ] life any
old people out there like me if you're
young you should [ __ ] do it it's the
greatest goddamn thing ever
there's
nothing better than like I you know
other than heating right and that type
of stuff
finding love and not having your
quarterback suspended for four games
over some County air pressure there's
nothing better than that just being able
to move your [ __ ] body and stretching
is the best really yoga Pilates all of
that [ __ ] is probably the best [ __ ] you
can do because it really keeps you in
shape it really keeps you flexible
without hurting yourself I can't help it
I'm a child of the 80s so I'll always
have that world gym gold gym push it up
nope okay I always have to [ __ ] you
know dude what are you benching what are
you benching that kid I always had
that's always gonna be in me but anyways
these foam rollers I'm telling you
they're the [ __ ] so but I never heard of
this this kids recommending the stick
doesn't it sound like a paid
advertisement it isn't he said I can fit
it in my carry-on you know be great as
if this kid invented it he's actually
getting a free commercial he said I can
fit it in my carry-on or in my gear bag
so it travels a lot better than any foam
roller and it's a lot easier to do just
sitting in a chair and not having to
roll around on the floor you might like
it it's what keeps me functional when I
have three or four hurling games crazy
ancient Irish sport to play in a day at
a tournament we'll wait a minute lady
wait I got to look this up you know if
it's an Irish sport you know two things
you know it's [ __ ] crazy and you know
there's nobody stretching hurling it
show somebody puking okay it's an Irish
game resembling field hockey all right
am I trying to start anything with
Ireland but uh that's a woman's sport
over here they run around wearing skirts
and I know you guys don't do the killed
thing so what the [ __ ] is going on here
all right played with the shorter stick
in a broader oval blade it's a national
game of Ireland and may date back to the
second millennium BC all right so you're
all forgiven you didn't know any better
all right let's see some images for this
thing oh [ __ ] that that's not a that's a
club I would play that [ __ ] game
that is a [ __ ] Club Jesus Christ look
at those [ __ ] helmets they wear it
look like [ __ ] Butch goring and then
somebody took a welding class for the
first time ever butch gorings hockey
helmet butch gorings hockey helmet by
the way it's Liz legendary he had the
same piece-of-shit helmet I think for
right up from the juniors and he just
paint every time he went to a new team
he would just paint it I remember he
finished with the did he finish with the
Bruins I've already played with us all
those were the days oh those were the
days Jesus Christ look at this guy
taking one of those [ __ ] paddles
right to the face well okay I get
shit-faced and watch that
that is the weirdest looking thing I've
ever seen it's like it looks like the
beginning of a goalie stick and then you
amputated it right just beyond the heel
about a third of the way up the blade
all right so this gain or to die really
appreciate that I'm gonna check that out
the stick good stuff thank you
all right Chyna hi Billy Boy I'm Iranian
living in China Jesus he goes Yeah right
Iranian I think the only place that you
might not have any fans is North Korea
and that's only because they don't have
access to the Internet anyways I have
watched oh speaking of which Jade who I
worked with this week is Brazilian and
she mentioned you know she was thinking
about maybe doing some stand-up down in
Brazil and how that scene is starting to
get going and uh I was just wondering
anybody from Brazil listening and if you
do if you have any suggestions because
I've always wanted to take my wife down
there she's always wanting to go and I'd
love to go down there I guess it's cold
this time of year right my wife's not
into the cold I personally like it you
know what I mean that's all good for me
I have no problem with that whatsoever
but uh let me know what's going on down
there and I'm psyched you guys are
getting some stand-up [ __ ] going because
I'd like to see your Chappelle's Louis
CK's and David tells that's what I'm
looking forward to all these like India
and all these places that are starting
to get comedians I can't wait to see
the Great's that come out of those those
different cultures alright so anyways
let me continue on here anyways I've
watched all your videos on YouTube and
followed your podcasts for more than six
months
you are indeed a funny guy though my
Chinese wife does not get your jokes
women around the world do not like my
act maybe I should charge her change her
to one with better taste I think he's
giving me [ __ ] there he goes I think you
have so many fans here especially among
expatriates well if you're in Hong Kong
yeah I did a show out there he goes I
don't know if you've ever been in China
but really hope you get your ass here
someday looking forward to hearing back
from you please [ __ ] yourself everyday
in the morning before breakfast yeah I
was in Hong Kong last year I've never
been to the mainland but I heard when
you go to the mainland it's just
straight Chinese you know what I mean
like all the expatriates seemed to be in
Hong Kong so I would go to mainland
China but I just feel like other than
seeing the Great Wall and eating some
delicious food I don't think I could do
a show up there because that it would be
worried that not enough people would be
able to understand what I'm saying and
even if they could understand it I think
maybe I just I don't know I think they'd
be like your wife like I don't get what
he's talking about anyways okay
continuing on Hillary hot sauce old hot
sauce Hilary yo Billy listen to your
Thursday podcasts and a bit about
Hillary and the hot sauce is actually
true there are interviews with her
talking about this over a decade or so
apparently in the 90s she learned how
healthy was to eat hot peppers and so
she did and she grew to love hot sauce
it's also known that she kept a lot of
hot sauces at the White House where she
lived anyways for some reason I felt bad
for her so I thought I'd write you well
here's the [ __ ] thing you know what
you know what I like I like fried
chicken okay I would never bring that up
if I was talking to a bunch of black
people trying to get their votes you
know what I mean even if she is into it
what'd you just say she is fine it's
still a [ __ ] it was it was just tacky
hot sauce I always had you know wasn't
lipstick it wasn't anything like that
all the other [ __ ] that she has yeah
I just don't buy it and I just think
they're lying sacks of [ __ ] and I've had
20 years experience watching them on TV
I lived in New York when she was the
center there senator there I watched
Bill Clinton for eight [ __ ] years I
can't stand them I think they'll
literally [ __ ] say anything
I think they've bought and paid for they
are the [ __ ] devil not literally
they're evil but they're just the same
evil that you're dealing with and it
doesn't make a difference as she's black
if she's got a dick or a vagina it's
gonna be more the same if you pick her
and I think that's why you have to
[ __ ] extreme people I think people
are sick of that and that's why Bernie
still in it and Trump is still in it
because I think generally speaking
people know that whatever the [ __ ] we're
doing it's not working it's not [ __ ]
working so and maybe it's no maybe
nobody can fix it you know I mean you
got [ __ ] what if for 500 million
people you can get to all the get them
all to try to tug the rope in the same
direction I mean that's it's a very
difficult thing to do and I don't know I
just wish the election was tomorrow
would you just get it over with I saw
this funny sign on the internet they
said 2016 everybody sucks Oh or
something like that something about all
the candidates nobody there's not and I
butchered it I have to fill out you know
what and to make up for me just
butchering that thing I might have to
put the the picture of it which I
probably won't be able to find so I
think I'll just have to take it that I
[ __ ] that up
alright let's read the last two
advertisings here advertisements
advertising's Sherry's berries where the
[ __ ] are they goddamnit
all right here we go oh I should
probably make a prediction here right I
don't know you know what I'd have no
prediction for Game seven
I want the Blues to win [ __ ] you know
what [ __ ] it
you know what I'm not gonna say anything
cuz at this point blues fans are gonna
hate me if I [ __ ] predict them again
you know people get all [ __ ] with
that mojo [ __ ] you're gonna jinx um [ __ ]
it I'm just gonna watch the game
alright Dollar Shave Club everybody
dollarshaveclub.com as a special offer
for new members who joined today you'll
get a free month of exit of the
executive razor razor when you buy a tub
of dr. Carver's shave butter also known
as dr. Kavi ZZ shea butter this is the
first time they've ever done something
like this and once you tried Dollar
Shave Club duck once you try
dollarshaveclub.com you'll become a
proud member like millions of others one
reason is because they deliver amazing
razors right to your door for a third of
the price of what the greedy razor
corporations charge said that means when
you join to all the shape Club you can
afford to shave with a fresh blade
anytime you want which feels phenomenal
you'll get a first-class shave when you
use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet another reason is the dr.
can using it with the executive razor
makes the blade glide gently for the
smoothest shave ever dr. Carver's shea
butter isn't your average shave cream
it's a unique condition conditioning
formula with high quality natural
ingredients leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth and right
now new members will get a tub of shaved
butter and get the executive razor for
free they've never done this before take
advantage of it it's only available by
going to dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / alright blue
apron okay you need to learn how to cook
you need to know how to cook I should
say not only do you like do you feel
like you know your way around a kitchen
but cooking at home means eating
healthier and saving money instead of
ordering an expensive takeout again well
where do you start
blue apron has you covered for less than
$10 per meal blue apron delivers all
fresh ingredients all the fresh
ingredients you need to create
home-cooked meals just follow the easy
step-by-step instructions each meal can
be prepared in 40 minutes or less no
overwhelming trips to the grocery store
no more sad takeout no matter your your
dietary preferences blue apron makes it
a breeze to discover and prepare dishes
like pan roast
chicken with Lanciano kale and blue
potato hash
I can't even say half this [ __ ] I saw
Marin posted a picture it looked
delicious brothy yuzu cod with soba
noodles locked in is this even real
stuff use a juice and soba noodles steak
and grains of paradise and mashed
plantains pink lemon question mark I
don't know it's your [ __ ] the [ __ ] do I
know arroz con pollo cod fish and chips
with aioli I know that word pork roast
and whole roasted carrots with brown
butter spinach I've [ __ ] I get it
quiche with TK products am I really
supposed to read all of this spinach
with red lettuce spice chickpea burgers
I start crying here with fat of in sweet
potatoes bad lemon yogurt sauce kale
sweet [ __ ] get it with soft boiled
eggs and quinoa and all that I hit with
it where the [ __ ] the rest of the copy
I don't know go to blue apron calm slash
bar click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in burp I hope
that's what I was supposed to say Jesus
Christ aid like type the whole [ __ ]
menu tell like I was introduced in the
[ __ ] wu-tang all right cash cash and
banking I listened to your podcast today
and about money how is just a number
while relating to paychecks I couldn't
agree more
that they are intentionally phasing out
cash period every payday I go to the
bank and I take out all of my cash
except what is needed to cover my bills
and the bank people look at me like I'm
an idiot on a regular basis I walk out
of there with 7 to 8 grand in cash at
least once or twice a month and they
actually interrogate me about why I'm
taking all my money out of the bank and
how come I don't need my money and in
the bank all my friends think I'm a
conspiracy theorist because I buy silver
by the pound and other precious metals
dude you need to shut up stop telling
your friends that you do this [ __ ]
you're opening yourself up to get robbed
alright just act like you just taken
everything down to the [ __ ] Bank why
are you telling me this alright all my
friends think I'm a conspiracy
by silver I got I refuse to keep money
in the bank and if we ever go into a
Great Depression the government
collapses they're going to seize
everybody's money in the bank accounts
guaranteed so I'll keep all my cash
hidden at home which if the currency
crash is really in the end it doesn't do
me any good because it won't be worth
[ __ ] but I don't like the government to
know how much money I have at any given
moment I think it's a good practice so
yeah I think people should take their
money out of the bank every payday
actual physical money and dollar bills
plus when I have the cash in my hand and
I run out of it there's no way I can
spend more than I have I also don't
believe in credit cards everything I
bought was with cash even cars thirty
thousand dollar cars bought with cash it
may throw up a few red flags but [ __ ]
them no it doesn't not if you're you
know not if you're if you're paying
taxes on all once you deposit it in the
bank there's a record of it and I think
the bank's want to know what you're
doing with it they always want to know
what you're doing with your money
because they want to make money off your
money so what you do every week by
giving them money is you give them an
interest-free loan on their money I
guess they give you a couple of points
interest they provide the service of
keeping your money safe allegedly even
though they're a bunch of crooks and
then they loan it out to your fellow
countrymen at super high rates and you
know this is nothing to if you put seven
eight grand in there they can loan seven
eight thousand Biggins a hundred percent
loan out all that money like I don't
know like times three or some some [ __ ]
it's crazy
back in the day like when you ran a bank
responsibly what it's safe he had ten
grand in the bank you could only loan
out like there was a certain percentage
you couldn't go past like thirty percent
I can't remember what it was but you
know so the money was still there and
they the bankers through paying off
politicians kept getting that money that
number the percentage bumped up and up
and up and up and they kept getting more
and more deregulated more and more
deregulated now when you put the money
in they can loan it you put a thousand
in they can loan they can loan out not
only a hundred percent of that thousand
they can loan like another $3,000
for that thousand thousand for you you
you and you so they basically
counterfeited like three grand as far as
this [ __ ] that I've read and I haven't
looked that stuff up for a while things
might have changed after 2008 but it's
it's a pretty shady thing but I will
tell you I don't feel comfortable having
a bunch of cash in the [ __ ] house you
know I always hear the first 48 plane in
my head so you know good luck to you you
know what I did after a while I just
tapped out a conspiracy theory I got a
[ __ ] dog i watch sports and I just I
just I take comfort knowing that I can
only die once that's what I do alright
okay oh Jesus another [ __ ] hair loss
thing is syste me another guy asked me
should I shave my head should I not
shave my head she like glue something on
there hey old flowers to a billion I'll
keep it short parentheses and thinning
I've been losing my hair for the past
couple years it's thinning at the top
and has been doing so for six years I
know you've gone through the same
predicament now you're very perceptive
I'm gonna go out on a limb I think I
know I think you know what I'm talking
about here he goes I am I know it
shouldn't matter and should I should
probably just shave it but I love my
hair my god do I love my hair I remember
when I used to get my hair cut every
barber a stylist stylist I went to said
how it was so thick and I would never
have to worry about going bald those
lying [ __ ] so when it started thinning
I I like most guys started reading
everything I could I found out that most
men have had success with propecia it's
a one day a pill that you take sixty
percent of men have regrowth well 30
percent keep what they have now what
does that mean 60 percent have regrowth
and thirty percent of that 60 percent
yeah I guess that that would be yeah
that's obviously what that we keep what
they have no or is that the other thirty
sixty percent keep what they have no 60
percent Jesus Christ people have
regrowth 30 percent keep what they have
so now we up to 90 percent yeah I guess
you would be and it seems not to work
for about 10 percent of men
so it seems like a no-brainer to at
least try right well for about two
percent of men all right dude you said
60 30 10 and now two we're up to 102
percent here so there's some [ __ ]
overlap it makes their dick not work
they complain of a weaker - no erections
since look look sorry that's [ __ ]
hilarious see keep your hair to get the
girl he'd come home and then your dick
doesn't work that's exactly why I don't
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] cuz you can never
have your cake and eat it so I just feel
like there's gotta be some sort of
damage that it does that's just you know
dude I'm 48 years old what am I gonna
join a boy band it's [ __ ] over do you
know I gotta be honest with you if you
don't fight aging it's pretty painless
you know I go to the gym you know I keep
myself in good shape but all of that
other [ __ ] these [ __ ] this [ __ ]
one was telling me this weekend that
that out here in Hollywood you know or
possibly around the country I don't know
they have this is the most the most
disgusting thing as far as vanity I
think I've heard in a long time do you
know they have they have Botox parties
like they come over they drink drinks
they watch a show or something like that
and then he can go over and you get like
that [ __ ] that makes your face look like
the Joker just shot into your face like
this foreign chemical under your skin
you know I guess it's just skull right
there and it is protecting your brain
but I just feel like somehow it's got a
leak in there right it goes into your
[ __ ] blood stream or something
somehow it ends up in your brain I just
see you just literally injecting
chemicals into your [ __ ] face it's
the amount of people that won't do
heroin but we'll put Botox in their body
it's just I don't know I guess it's
whatever the [ __ ] you're into I don't
know I like I said if you just accept
the fact that you know you're no longer
young and you dress your age you know
you you you don't look that you know if
you keep yourself in shape you you look
fine you know what I mean you don't look
sexy you're not attractive but you
shouldn't be you should have gotten all
that out of your [ __ ] system this
whole [ __ ] thing
that you got like these decent you know
these broads on the [ __ ] real
housewives walking around they're
bedazzled jeans they got like four kids
and they still [ __ ] pudding
you know hooker jeans on it's like what
are you doing you're a mom you know the
husband's walking around with [ __ ]
tank tops on I just don't understand a
sport coat he's supposed to be adults I
don't know I blame Madonna no I don't
she looks great what am I talking about
Bob you know he goes oh what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] shut up you'd still bang
her alright Sudbury the ugliest place in
Ontario Canada dear Billy BER please
talk about your experience traveling
through Sudbury I didn't think it was
ugly I thought it was cool did you
notice how there were no trees in the
area above ten feet taller so most of
the vegetation in the area was destroyed
by acid rain be caused by the massive
mining operations in and around Sudbury
our stupid tourist attraction is the
largest nickel in the world
luckily they solve the population
problem by building a gigantic
smokestack currently the second largest
freestanding chimney in the world to
spread the pollution out over a larger
area industry has been winding down so
now we have more unemployed hard-working
Canadian rednecks than ever great place
can't wait to get anywhere else that's
[ __ ] hilarious my person may have a
future as a writer men CL [ __ ] humour
works when you hate what you live I
didn't hate where I live but I mean
there's just certain things they can
[ __ ] bring it out of you
I had no idea I didn't know anything
anything about that I had a great time
when I was up there and you know I'm a
nerd when it comes to travelling I like
going to places I haven't been to and at
this point there's nothing I like doing
better than not going to the major city
I've been to all of them a thousand
[ __ ] times they're great but I don't
know I like going I like going to the
other places des moines Deadwood
right that when I went to and [ __ ]
Louisiana begins with an S I can't
remember wasn't New Orleans that doesn't
begin with an S Schenectady Shreveport
right now [ __ ] anyways open relations
hi there Billy bald bags what the [ __ ]
is up with open relationships these days
I'm a 37 year old lady unexpectedly
widowed I'm sorry to hear that and after
eight years after eight years with my
husband I'm getting back out there in
the dating world and have discovered a
plethora of people who are in in open or
polyamorous relationships I don't know
what polyamorous means alright open
relationship means like yeah you know
keep it clean I don't want to know about
it don't make make sure it's nobody I
know
polyamorous amour dude is a practice or
desire for intimate relationships
evolving more than two people also they
have threesomes together that's so
[ __ ] weird there's a couple like
break down the game tape afterwards like
I just felt like you lick your [ __ ] a
little bit better than mine you know do
you make like halftime adjustments and
when you switching positions open
relationship does it get me in trouble
rules to be looking at this online this
is my search engine open relationships
six rules of four doing the whole open
relation thing right one don't do it -
don't do it alright open relationship
already okay here we go
one understand what an open relationship
actually is there's a lot of confusion
confusion confusion about what is and
what isn't an open relationship some
people who are in long-distance
relationships say they are in an open
relationship they both hook up with
whoever but just don't talk about it by
the word open connotes honesty alright
see they have to know about an open
relationship acknowledge that Cup
can have their needs met by other people
if you're really okay with that why keep
it a secret
all right it's actually a great point if
you are okay with it it shouldn't bug
you what'd you do today honey on the way
home and I got a pizza oh that's great I
take thunder games Hunger Games [ __ ]
they call Thunder games make sure you're
doing it right doing it for the right
reasons are you interested in an open
relationship just because you want to be
with other people or is it that you're
interested in physical experiences with
other people but you want to stay
committed to sharing your emotional and
spiritual self with one person s where
it gets complicated set some boundaries
every person every person's guidelines
are different but there are always
things to think about before you enter
into an open relationship do you both
need to be present in order for sex with
other people to be okay can you be with
one gender and not the other are certain
sex acts off the table these are all
important things this is just like the
early days at USC all right no more eye
gouging you can't do that thing where
the other guy puts the finger in your
ass and then you go alright I give I
give
all right that's actually a wrestling
move you can believe it anyone you hope
tell your other partners anyone you hook
up with outside your relationship
deserves to know the deal
try say something like I find you
attractive but you should know my
partner and I are in an open
relationship
so there's someone else in my life that
way they can be fully informed okay
keep it healthy that's obvious have
regular check-ups there you go all right
so now that I'm a little more [ __ ]
educated what the [ __ ] did that just say
Oh sixty turn-ons for better sex I
thought of it turn-ons for over 60 I
think I am a little dyslexic alright so
she says she's getting in there and
everybody okay so there's a bunch of
like husbands and wives looking to hook
up with her or people who are saying
that they're in open relationships
because I've recently started dating a
great guy who lives with the mother of
his kids in a supposedly sexless
domestic partnership we have a
great connection and we enjoy each
other's company but he doesn't have a
lot of extra chill time due to his
family commitments I have kids too the
same age as his even I keep telling him
let's all hang out together but he is
hesitant which makes me question the
openness of his open relationship or
maybe he just wants to [ __ ] you alright
I keep telling let's hang out together
okay I should have walked away sooner
but he gives really good head Jesus
Christ I'm not ready for anything too
serious I just wish he had more time to
spend with me socially this seems to be
more and more common these I'm so cool
and modern I'm going to [ __ ] you and
then go home to my wife hipsters should
I keep seeing this guy thanks for your
insight I'm a former Bostonian living in
Hawaii I'm a huge fan you keep me
laughing through some hard times and I
[ __ ] love your old freckled face mwah
no thank you
um I would say yeah I I don't know
that's all [ __ ] look if you just want
to [ __ ] around but like this guy
obviously does yeah he obviously doesn't
want to do anything more even if he
didn't have a wasn't with somebody else
if he doesn't want to hang out with you
then that means he just wants to be [ __ ]
buddies which is totally cool if you
know that that's the deal if you're
alright with that I would continue
seeing him if you're not I would move on
and if you're sick of meeting people
like that I'm sure there's men who that
didn't work I was gonna say men who are
sick of meeting women who are in an open
relationship yeah guys would be like
yeah that's cool you don't want to hang
out perfect up top sounds good to me
yeah if you're your age
how busy you are and all that [ __ ] I'm
not trying to be a dick I'm ten years
old again so I'm not talking down to you
37 you got [ __ ] kids the kinds of
people you're gonna meet in the civilian
world are also gonna be married with
kids I'm saying or divorced I mean I
would join it I would join a dating site
that's what I would do and just say what
you want I would [ __ ] go out and try
and find it when you're ready when
you're ready but um you know as far as
all that other [ __ ] I mean that's up to
you I have no I have no [ __ ] idea it
just made me happy then I'm [ __ ] back
and Jesus Christ more and more [ __ ]
brutal goddamn [ __ ]
I'm imma get to I know you guys all
heard the some sad news about comedians
this past week man I just [ __ ] brutal
absolutely [ __ ] brutal maybe feel very
lucky and blessed so once again thank
you to everybody that keeps coming out
to my shows and that's it that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in
on you on Thursday and that's it don't
take any [ __ ] out there you [ __ ]
[ __ ]